Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Linus. Guten Morgen Tim.
Logbuch Netzpolitik, die, was haben wir denn?
Achtundachtzig.
Achtundachtzigste Ausgabe. Keine Assoziationen bitte. Ähm ja, wir warten ja auf das Geschenk der großen Koalition, ne? Zu Weihnachten.
Ja, ist ja noch ein bisschen hin. Heute schreiben wir den zehnten Dezember und das war, glaube ich, zum vierzehnten.
Hat sich denn schon die äh große vaterländische äh sozialdemokratische Partei durchgerungen, dem faulen Kompromiss zuzustimmen oder müssen wir noch warten? Nee, es gab doch, also.
Nee, es gab doch, also es gab doch jetzt erstmal diesen großen äh diese große Bohei mit den Jusos,
dann gab es äh die Drohanrufe.
Von wem?
Ähm von ja anonyme Drohanrufe aus dem Willy-Brandt-Haus ereilten, verschiedene Landesverbände der SPD.
Ja genau, das ist doch gefälligst für die Große Koalition äh zu stimmen hätte.
Ne, da wurden dann halt schöne Argumente Argumente dafür vorgelesen und irgendwie mit Willy Brandt Zitaten gemischt und äh es bekannte sich dann die hedonistische internationale zu diesen Drohanrufen gingen die jetzt äh ermittelt wird äh von Generalbundesanwalt und BKA,
wegen äh wenn ich.
Wegen des Vorlesens von Gerhard Schröder, äh Zitaten oder.
Wegen ähm dem äh eindringenden Computersystem, weil sie irgendwie vermutet haben, die hätten die Telefonanlage des Willy-Brandt-Hauses gehackt und äh wegen Nötigung.
Da die entsprechende Absendertelefonnummer auf äh.
Weiß ich nicht, aber das äh so wurde es wohl behauptet und äh Nötigung und noch irgendwas. Ja ja klar, also Scherzanruf äh ist äh ernstes Geschäft, ne. Da hast du schnell mal ähm.
Ja, wo leben wir denn, dass wir hier einfach so Witze machen können.
Dass man einfach mal so einen Scherzanruf machen könnte, ne, ohne dann.
Ja oder Bundeskanzler zitiert. Ich meine, am Ende werden die noch für das, was sie mal gesagt haben, ja, am Ende nimmt das noch jemand ernst.
Ja, also da da ist äh dieser Scherz äh ist hat gesessen, sonst würde ja da nicht mit so großen Rohren äh drauf gefeuert werden,
ich denke mal,
sich das äh relativ schnell dann in wohlgefallen auflösen wird, äh wenn der Sachverhalt vollständig aufgeklärt ist. Aber ja, das BKA ermittelt, generistische Internationale.
Ja, was ist denn hier unser erstes Thema heute?
Ja wir hatten ja schon vor einiger Zeit von dem Urteil berichtet des Kölner Landgerichts, in dem äh der Telekom gesagt wurde, liebe Freunde,
ähm,
mit eurer Drosseklausel, die ihr danachträglich reinschiebt und so, das ist nicht in Ordnung, wenn ihr Flatrate dran schreibt, muss auch Flatrate drin sein. Und wir hatten dann überlegt, ob denn die Telekom wohl,
hingehen würde, dagegen Berufung einlegt. Ähm das hat sie nicht getan,
sondern jetzt so eine Art Schamoffensive gestartet, wie ist die äh äh Schreiberlinge bei Heise nennen. Ähm.
Ist wohl eher eine Schamoffensive, also eine Scharmoffensive, ja? Also.
Schamoffensive, ja.
Aus voller Scham. Gehen sie jetzt in die Offensive.
Sagen, nur noch uneingeschränkte Tarife heißen jetzt Flatrate.
Mhm.
Und Flatrates sollen dafür dann teurer werden, ja? Sie sagen, es gibt jetzt günstige Volumentarife und echte Flatrates, ja? Womit klar ist so, okay, die Flatrate wird teurer.
Womit aber auch klar ist, dass es dann echte Flatrates gibt. Also ich meine, das finde ich.
Das wollen sie weiterhin anbieten, ja?
Das finde ich ja zumindest schon mal einen ganz interessanten Move, weil das war ja bisher unklar,
Bisher hieß es ja nur so, ja hier, wir haben ja die Flatrate und die Flatrate ist äh irgendwie beschränkt und äh beschnitten.
Und äh von daher finde ich das schon mal an sich ganz gut, dass es jetzt so ein klares äh Statement gibt, wie denn das Ganze sich so künftig äh differenziert.
Ja
Das ist schon äh nicht verkehrt, aber es heißt natürlich auch, dass de facto an der für die große Marktsituation sich nichts ändern wird, nämlich,
dass die meisten Kunden natürlich auf den günstigeren Tarif mit den Einschränkungen zurückgreifen werden, äh wären nur wenige Kunden dann den ähm die Flatrates nehmen. Das heißt, der der Normalfall wird ein Nutzer sein
eingeschränkt haben.
Das wird sich zeigen. Ich meine, davon kann man vielleicht ausgehen, aber zumindest ist äh die Zahl ist auf dem Tisch so und das ist auch das, woran sich die äh anderen messen lassen müssen letzten Endes, ne. Und von daher.
Naja, also sie sagen, es geht nämlich noch weiter. Sie sagen für alle Kunden, die bereits Festnetzverträge mit einer Volumenbeschränkung,
gebucht haben, die kriegen auch weiterhin ohne Einschränkungen eine Flatrate. Das heißt, alles, was im,
Was sie bis jetzt alles, also alle Drosselklaus sind, die sie bis jetzt im Nachhinein in ihre Verträge geschoben haben, sind unwirksam und sogar auch die
in den Neuverträgen, die jetzt in den letzten Monaten abgeschlossen wurden, in denen sich solche Drosseln befanden. Befanden.
Und ich frage mich, was mit den alten Verträgen ist in den diese Drosselklauseln schon drin waren, bevor diese Diskussion aufkam.
Alles, wo jemals zur zum Zeitpunkt der Buchung Flatrate dranstand, äh wird nicht gedruck.
Ja, es stand ja nicht unbedingt überall dran, das heißt ja dann Call und Surf.
Colon Surf und Entertaining äh darauf bezog sich das Urteil.
Tarife, Call und Surf und die Tarife Tarifgruppe Entertain. Jetzt blickt natürlich auch keine Sau mehr durch bei diesen äh bei dem Tarifdschungel, den die Telekom da immer bastelt, ne, aber ähm das.
Das heißt, ich habe jetzt hier auch endlich eine Flatrate. Jetzt.
Du hast jetzt endlich eine Flatrate. Ja, also ganz einfach, ne? Alles Flatrate, wo nicht, äh wo wo nicht Drossel dran steht. Und auch da, wo Drossel dran stand und trotzdem Flat.
Aber dann müssen sie aber im Prinzip eine neue Vertragsausfertigung zu.
Werden sie tun.
Haben sie auch gesagt, wann sie das tun werden.
Irgendwann noch in diesem Monat.
Wow, na siehste mal, da ist doch mal ein Weihnachtsgeschenk.
Da ist dein Weihnachtsgeschenk, da kommen noch mehr dieses Jahr.
Aber, wie gesagt, man sollte da jetzt,
Also sie sagen dann, außerdem, wollen sie noch irgendwie so einen, so ein Verbraucherportal? Haben sie irgendwie ein ein in eine Idee für einen Verbraucherportal, wo man ein einheitliche Vergleichsmöglichkeiten von Tarifen schaffen könnte? Ähm
Ich bin mal gespannt, was da so ihre Politik sein wird. Ja, ich meine, die fahren,
Streckenweise ja sehr gut mit ihren ähm Handytarifen, wo sie die ähm die Flatrate mit dem,
mit dem höchsten äh mit dem höchsten Volumen enorm teuer machen. Also ich glaube, die kostet irgendwie um die hundert Euro, ne, so eine iPhone einmal alles, ich möchte glücklich sein, Flat.
Es gibt da keine Flat.
Ich red da von TED Telefonaten. Da geht's irgendwie.
Ja, aber ich meine, das Interessante ist, Sie haben ja jetzt bisher nur von DSL-Tarifen gesprochen, was es mit dem Mobilfunktarif.
Da wollen sie das auch so ähnlich anbringen. Ich möchte ganz kurz also so, sie haben,
Sie haben Telefon, sie haben Telefone und es gibt da verschiedene Flat-Flatrates, ja, mit mit Inklusiv-Volumen, ja? Und eigentlich ist doch nur dieser höchste Tarif so und so L oder XL, mit dem kannst du wirklich
die ganze Zeit telefonieren. Und die meisten haben dann so einen M-Tarif, wo du irgendwie hundert oder zweihundert Minuten,
drin hast. Ja, man sieht, ich kenne mich da nicht besonders aus. Der entscheidende Trick ist, dass sie dir eigentlich was, dass sie den Leuten etwas verkaufen, was so knapp,
unter dem Durchschnitt liegt, was die Leute eigentlich brauchen.
So dass die Leute denken, ah, ich habe den günstigeren Tarif genommen, dann aber für jede Minute und SMS, die außerhalb dieses Inklusivvolumens liegen
sehr stark zuschlagen, ne? Da kostet dann die SMS zwanzig Cent die Minute zwanzig Cent oder so, was ja so völlig inakzeptable ähm Preise eigentlich sind,
Also wenn, du hast das jetzt hier gerade auf. Dieser M-Tarif, den ich ansprach, siebenhundertfünfzig MB mit drin, ja? Und,
und irgendwie hundert Telefon äh hundertmal telefonieren, also. Ähm hundert Minuten, ach so, ist beim S, wie auch immer, die heißen ja immer anders, aber es Entscheidende ist,
dass sie eventuell die Drosselei sein lassen, sondern dich einfach einer volumenbasierten Berechnung unterziehen, wenn du aus deinem,
monatlich veranschlagten Volumen rausgehst.
Ja gut, das war ja auch bisher schon so teilweise. Also je nach.
Festnetztarifen.
Mobilfunk.
Das wäre natürlich genauso ähm genauso schlecht.
Ja gut, aber dann werden die Leute natürlich auch äh,
gegen überteuerte Aufschläge äh vorgehen. Ich meine, interessant ist, dass ja die Telekom im Prinzip jetzt gemerkt hat, dass sie nicht machen können, was sie wollen. Das finde ich ja schon mal äh ganz äh hilfreich.
Vielleicht ist es ein sehr optimistischer Blick auf die Situation, aber unserer Einschätzung nach,
der letzten Sendung haben wir jetzt unbedingt mit diesem Ergebnis so nicht unbedingt gerechnet. Ja, also schon, dass sie vielleicht irgendwann Flatrate-Flatrate sein lassen, aber äh,
dass das auch so der juristische Backlash da so unmittelbar ist, glaube ich, nicht hätte nicht jetzt unbedingt jeder gedacht.
Also ich, ich traue denen trotzdem nicht übern Weg und wir werden sehen, äh wo das hinführt. Man kann da auf jeden Fall sagen, dass der äh dass dieses Verfahren der Verbraucherzentrale ähm,
Wirklich einen enormen Impakt hatte.
Mhm.
Und da kann man, habe ich auch damals nicht großartig mit gerechnet und das ist schon eine eine feine Sache. Und man sieht, dass die Telekom da nicht nur äh Minimal nachgibt, sondern da tatsächlich irgendwie umdenkt, wie sie denn,
ähm ihr Verlangen nach Mehreinnahmen.
Genau und wie sie dann vor allem in der Öffentlichkeit nicht unbedingt so als wäre äh ihr Netz funktional kaputt. Insofern zwei zu null für Clemens.
Mal sehen. Halbzeitstand sagen wir. Zur Halbzeit zwei null. Ja.
Ja, zur Halbzeit zwei null. Das ist schon mal nicht schlecht. Gut.
Ja, dann schöne, schöne Geschichte, schöne Geschichte, also eine eine so eine richtig schöne Geschichte, wie man sie so wie man sie äh schon kennt,
aus aus den Jahren, als wir uns im Internet noch so mit mit Abmahnungen und und Urheberrechtsverletzungen ähm auseinandergesetzt haben, vermehrt, weil's das noch so der größte Aufreger des Netzes war?
Und zwar geht die Geschichte so,
Der Berliner Anwalt Daniel Sebastian spricht beim Landgericht Köln vor und sagt, ja,
Er hätte hier eine Liste von IP-Adressen und äh die hätten also gegen das Urheber äh Recht verstoßen, den die Person hinter diesen IP-Adressen und er hätte gerne so eine Nutzerfeststellung gemacht.
Ja? Und das Landgericht Köln ähm,
verbrieft dieses Auskunftsersuchen an die Telekom und lässt die Nutzer dieser IP-Adressen feststellen,
Mit der Begründung, dass diese Nutzer unbefugt öffentlich äh geschützte Werke,
zugänglich gemacht hätten, ja? Also das klassische, das Teilnehmen an einer Tauschbowlbörse und das liegt, das stellt ja eine äh Rechtsverletzung des Paragraph neunzehn Urhebergesetzes dar.
Ja, ihr bösen, bösen Falsche, ihr.
Genau, ihr wart falsch, das ist wichtig. Damit haben sie das begründet und äh von der Telekom, die bei sowas ja immer sehr schnell ist, ja, das hat sich ja auch inzwischen rumgesprochen.
Also warte mal, wer hat das begründet, das Gericht oder der Anwalt? Der Anwalt hat da nichts zu gesagt oder was?
Komme ich ja gleich zu. Ich erzähle die Geschichte ja absichtlich so.
Okay, ich frag ja nur ein bisschen.
So, man muss ja immer so kleine Twists haben, um dann noch so kleine Höhepunkte, so Spitzen in der in der Geschichte.
Weil's es muss sich ja irgendwie bemerkbar machen, dass wir zwei Stunden lang am Drehbuch für jede Sendung schreiben.
Dramaturgisch äh äh habe ich mich jetzt entschieden, das so zu erzählen.
So und dann kommt äh Telekom und sagt, ja klar, hier, zack, äh wir äh liefern unsere Nutzer ins Messer, ist ja bekannt. So, es ist, wie gesagt, sowieso immer so. Fragt mal Leute, die eine Abmahnung bekommen haben, welchen Internet-Provider die haben. In der Regel Telekom,
ja Anmerkungen, die meisten haben auch ein Telekom-Vertrag, deswegen ist die Grundwahrscheinlichkeit, dass du solche Personen hast, äh höher, aber ähm es ist äh Telekom ist da im Verbraucherschutz, wie gesagt, ne. Und jetzt bekommen diese Leute,
Eine Abmahnung von der Regensburger Kanzlei Uhrmann und Kollegen,
ja? Das sind die, die sind äh auch inzwischen schon so richtige Player im Abmahn-Business, ja. Die haben äh den Porno-Pranger damals äh ins Feld geführt.
Die Freude.
Sie haben auch schon mal irgendwie ausbleibende Zahlung von von säumigen Abmahnungsopfern öffentlich versteigert, ja? Also die sind die sind die sind bekannt, ja, U und C, ja?
Und die äh schicken also jetzt eine eine Abmahnung an die,
an diese Internetnutzer, in denen ihnen vorgeworfen wird, ein Schweinchenvideo geguckt zu haben,
Und zwar auf dem Streamingportal mit dem Namen Red Tube.
Schweinchen-Video.
So Schaukelvideo halt. Wo Menschen schaukeln. Wir haben ja auch junge Hörerinnen,
So, also Woody, Rudi was machen, wo Erwachsene schaukeln. So und ähm jetzt ist aber interessant, Streaming-Video, ja, Red Tube. So, dass eine eine Streaming-Seite und keine Tauschbörse,
Und so heißt es dann auch in der Abmahnung und da sieht man, dass die sehr wohl wussten, was sie da tun. Durch die technischen, notwendige Zwischenspeicherung,
Ja, also der Stream kommt aus dem Internet durch die Telekom-Leitung in deinen Computer geschossen,
ist dort im Arbeitsspeicher. Puffert sich so ein bisschen auf, geht durch deinen Prozessor, durch deine durch dein Motherboard in die Grafikkarte, durch den Monitor, erreich dein Auge, ja? In diesem Rahmen,
Hat ja technisch eine Kopie, eine Vervielfältigung stattgefunden.
Wenn auch nur kurzfristig.
Kopieren, ist kopieren. Zack! Und.
Ich meine, das ist ja ungefähr so, als würde man als hätte man früher den Leuten irgendwie das äh Kopieren von Hollywoodfilmen, die Opfer der ARD ausgestrahlt werden, unterstellt, weil ja der Film,
der Phosphorschicht der Röhre,
speichert wird, weil ja es sind ja Halbbilder, die müssen ja nachleuchten und von daher müssen sie ja da auch zwischengespeichert werden, weil sonst ergibt sich ja kein vollständiges Bild.
Tim, du bringst die Leute in Teufelskirche.
Ein Fuchs.
So, aber da und damit haben wir zum ersten Mal eine Abmahnung für Nutzung eines Streamingportales,
in Deutschland und zwar direkt an mehrere hundert Leute. Es geht ja noch weiter. Jetzt sagen sie darunter ja, da hätten wir gerne, dann von ihnen eine Unterlassungserklärung,
und zweihundertfünfzig Euro. Fünfzehn Euro davon sind Schadensersatz,
fünfundsechzig Euro sind die äh nicht näher benannten Aufwendungen für die Ermittlungen.
So
Also im Wesentlichen die Dienstleistung der Telekom an der Stelle.
Na ja oder das äh das Schreiben der ganzen, des ganzen Miss an den Richtern, ne. Es gibt aber noch ein viel größeres Problem. Ich bin's interessant, dass du dir die Frage noch gar nicht stellst.
Was mit den restlichen äh Geld ist.
Nee, wo haben die die IP-Adressen her?
Von der Telekom hast du doch gesagt.
Naja und wo haben die die von der Telekom, haben sie die Namen zu den IP-Adressen? Ach so. Und wo haben sie die IP-Adressen her, die diese Seite genutzt haben?
Sehr gute Frage, weil es ist ja gar keine Tauschbörse, wo man sich bei Beton mal eben mit reinklinken kann und die äh Adressen geliefert bekommt. Da kann man ja eigentlich nur vom Serverbetreiber selber bekommen. Genau. Da haben sie die auch her.
Das weiß man nicht.
Und der also ne, der Unterschied nochmal für für diejenigen, die äh die sich nicht ähm mit solchen Sachen so genau auseinandersetzen. Der Unterschied ist, die Abmahnungen, jeder, der bisher eine Fallsharing-Abmahnung bekommen hat,
Urheberrechtsverletzungsabmahnungen im Internet hat die bekommen, weil er das Werk öffentlich zugänglich gemacht hat. Genau das, was die Richter nämlich auch als Begründung der Telekom nannten, ja? Das heißt, du bist in dem Torent,
und du lädst nicht nur runter, sondern du lädst auch anderen Leuten hoch. Ja, was ja eine,
Aus verschiedenen Gründen sehr sinnvolle Art ist, äh Dateien zu verteilen in einem Netzwerk. Ähm und dabei wirst du da erwischt und dann wird dir gesagt, du bist jetzt äh böse, weil du hast,
aktiv weiterverbreitet.
Nicht der Fall.
Das ist hier nicht der Fall. Wer aktiv weiterverbreitet hat, war das Portal Red Tube selber. Jetzt könnte man natürlich sagen, okay,
Mit den IP-Adressen mal außen vor. Wenn,
auch, wenn man auf seine Streamingseite geht, verstößt man gegen Paragraph so und so dreiundfünfzig Urhebergesetz, wenn die Quelle,
Offensichtlich rechtswidrig ist. Ja, das ist aber bei diesem Retube nicht unbedingt der Fall. Ja, man könnte argumentieren, dass das bei diesem
Kino XTO dann doch relativ offensichtlich war diese äh oder Kino-TO, wo diese Handyvideos aus dem Kino dann da gestreamt wurden, ja?
Ähm.
Aber man, so die die also das ist der Unterschied, so jetzt fragt man sich, wenn doch eigentlich nur die Verbindung zwischen Retube und mir stattfindet? Und,
Die Telekom offensichtlich nicht irgendwie die Zugriffe auf Ratube überwacht hat, um die um ihre Nutzer ins Messer zu liefern, sondern nochmal die äh sondern extra mit einer Liste von IP-Adressen gerichtlich aufgefordert werden musste.
Woher haben sie dann die Alpi-Adresse? Und äh da gibt da, darüber hüllen sie sich in Schweigen, das wird also sehr interessant, denn,
der Weg, auf dem die ähm, na Moment, die man ja gerne ab. Also, es gibt es gäbe,
Verschiedene theoretische Möglichkeiten,
wie die Firma äh oder die verschiedenen Firmen, die hinter dieser Abmahnung stehen, an dieser IP-Adressen gelangt sein könnten. Einige davon sind unter Umständen auch genauso wenig legal. Ähm,
also was sie theoretisch hätten machen können, ist so eine Art,
falsche Domain aufsetzen, also statt Readube dot com, Readube dot net und einfach gucken, wer da was aufruft und die Leute auf die richtige Seite weiterladen, sich aber die IP-Adresse merken und sagen, der ist auf diese Seite gegangen. Ähm,
sie hätten vielleicht auch ähm,
Werbung auf der Seite schalten können und dann mit den Referern sehen können, ah, der lädt unsere Werbeanzeige mit.
Anderen erwachsenen Menschen die Schaukeln und.
Als Referer steht da oben drin, unser Video. Also hat der Nutzer das sich offensichtlich angeschaut. Also mahnen wir den einfach mal ab.
Hm, wäre alles möglich.
Gibt's jetzt verschiedene Möglichkeiten. Interessant ist, man kann jetzt drüber spekulieren. Ähm es ist nicht öffentlich, wie sie's gemacht haben.
Aber man kann zumindest,
vermuten, dass ja als Plattform selber eigentlich überhaupt gar kein Interesse daran hat, seine eigenen User zu verklagen, weil sonst müssten sie es ja gar nicht erst anbieten und letzten Endes sind das ja die Leute, die die Werbung anschauen und das ist quasi äh hinkam.
Mein, vielleicht haben sie auch einfach einen transparenten äh Proxi zwischen Retube und das Internet gehauen und da überwacht. Also man weiß es nicht. Eine Kooperation von Ray Tube kann man eigentlich ausschließen, weil Retube als ähm,
als äh in dem Fall Betreiber und Bereitsteller ist ja eigentlich dafür verantwortlich. Das sind ja diejenigen, die zugänglich machen. Das heißt, man könnte jetzt sogar noch sagen, also sofern eine Möglichkeit bietet,
Urheberrechtlich geschützte Werke dort entfernen zu lassen,
Könnte man sogar noch den diese Firmen die dahinter stehen noch ein Strick daraus treten dass sie genau das nicht getan haben,
Ja, sondern gesagt haben, okay, die bleiben drin und wir wollen jetzt an die Nutzer ran. Die sich das angucken.
Eine Verbreitung äh unterstellt wird äh mit der Konstruktion äh naja, sie haben ja auch gespeichert und wer potenziell äh zwischenspeichert ist ja auch schon fast ein Verbrecher.
Also sie hätten natürlich, sie wären.
Zwischenspeicherung nur.
Sie werden natürlich gezwungen gewesen, um um ernst zu nehmen zu bleiben, werden Sie natürlich gezwungen gewesen, ähm sofort ähm dafür zu sorgen, dass dieses, dass,
schwindet. Das haben sie aber offensichtlich nicht getan, sondern sie haben ja den den tatsächlichen Rechtsverstoß von Retube aktiv geduldet,
Gleichzeitig darauf geachtet, was die Nutzer tun. Also eine ganz haarige Angelegenheit, was sie da gemacht haben.
Geht da jetzt schon irgendjemand vor.
Ja, interessant ist, dass es äh also noch kurz diese Firma, die dahinter steht, also es gibt dann diese U und C, dann diesen Berliner Anwalt, äh Daniel Sebastian,
Urmann und Kollegen heißen die und dahinter steht dann noch irgendwie die Firma
Also Rechteinhaber dieser Videos scheint DAK zu sein, die im Jahr zweitausenddreizehn bereits einhundert solcher Nutzerfeststellungsanträge gestellt hat,
Dabei ging es mal um vierhundert, dann wieder um tausend IP-Adressen,
Äh zu den von den Providern eben die Auskunft verlangt wurde. Und der in dieser Firma ist dann wieder ein Pauf Reich, hat,
beschäftigt als Verwaltungsrat, der auch schon wieder 'ne lange Geschichte im Abmahnen Abmahnungswesen hat irgendwie mit verschiedenen Firmen Digi Protect oder so die dann irgendwie mal pleite gegangen sind und ähm,
Ja, also das sind Profis, Abmahnen, die machen halt seit Jahren damit äh ihr Geschäft so, ne.
Und jetzt kommt noch der der jetzt habe ich ja schon so, also wie sieht die IP-Adressen bekommen haben, ist äh absolut fraglich. Die äh,
IP-Adressen wurden herausgegeben an die Richter unter einem falschen Sachverhalt, weil die Richter gesagt haben, liebe Telekom, gib uns die Adressen, die das sind Tauschbörsennutzer, waren sie aber nicht. Das heißt, da haben wir ein Problem,
Und jetzt steht natürlich die Abmahnung selbst auch noch auf dünnem Eis, weil sie da irgendwie erzählen, ja, zwischenspeichern in deinem Arbeitsspeicher, bevor du's guckst und so. Und
Jetzt kommt der Knüller. Laut einem Urteil des Landgerichts München vom Juni zweitausenddreizehn
Ist fraglich, ob für Pornofilme überhaupt ähm ähm,
für Schaukelvideos überhaupt ein Urheberrechtsschutz besteht, weil,
ja. Also Voraussetzung für das Urheberrecht ist eine persönliche geistige Schöpfung und das ist bei,
Schaukelvideos,
nicht einwandfrei äh erwiesen.
Oh, Mann.
Also absolut windige, absolut windige Praxis hier. Ähm man kann also jedem und jeder, die ein solcher Abmahnungen erhalten hat, nur dazu raten,
ähm sich da der den jetzt kommt, was gibt's in Deutschland nicht? Sammelklagen gibt's nicht,
Aber es gibt irgendwie es gibt auf jeden Fall eine Rechtsanwaltskanzlei, die mehreren äh mehrere Empfänger solcher Abmahnungen vertritt,
und man kann nur dazu raten, sich an diese Rechtsanwaltskanzlei zu wenden und sich gegen diese Abmahnung zur Wehr zu setzen. Ähm es sind außerdem noch Fälle bekannt,
dass äh da in der Abmahnung dann gesagt wird, äh man hätte gegen jenes recht
von diesem Film verstoßen, hat aber dann einen Link auf einen anderen Film, an dem die Firma gar keine Rechte genießt, äh äh als Beweismittel angefügt. Also das ist, das steht auf sehr dünnem Eis und das sollte man sich unter keinen Umständen,
sollte man da klein beigeben. Ja, sowieso unter keinen Umständen diese Unterlassungserklärung,
unterzeichnen niemals, wenn wenn ihr eine Abmahnung bekommt. Ähm allenfalls diese äh Unterlassungserklärung modifizieren mit Hilfe eines Anwaltes,
Und ja, in dem Fall, also die zweihundertfünfzig Euro kann man sehr, sehr locker sparen.
Ja, wobei irgendwie reagieren muss man ja und äh von daher schon auch ein Anwalt ähm heranziehen im Zweifelsfall, oder?
Hm, also in dem Fall würde ich auf jeden Fall dazu raten, ähm,
sich mit einem Anwalt in Verbindung zu setzen oder eben abzuwarten, ob genug Leute zusammengekommen sind, die das, die das eh dann in so einer Sammel äh Dingverdingsung da, ich.
Ja, aber das ist ja das das Dumme an diesen Abmahnungen, dass also selbst, selbst wenn der Vorwurf selber,
sehr äh haarig ist. Gut, ich meine, wenn man eine Rechtsschutzversicherung äh hat, kann man die ranziehen, aber hier und das finde ich so ein bisschen auch das Verwerfliche an dieser ganzen Sache. Ne, man rechnet vermutlich damit,
Die Leute, weil es halt einfach hier um äh Schaukelvideos geht, ja? Und wir wissen, was die Gesellschaft immer noch für Verklemmung hat bei Schaukelvideos, äh dass sie dann halt nicht entsprechend ähm vorgehen aus,
Scham.
Genau, das ist das ist hier.
Schamoffensive.
Genau, das ist hier relativ offensichtlich der, dass das Kalkül der der Abmahnenden, dass sie sagen, na ja, da möchte ich ja mal sehen, wer damit zum zum Anwalt geht und sagt, ich habe hier äh ne.
Ja eben, das ist das Problem.
Ja. Also, interessant.
Gut, schreiten wir voran und äh blicken wir doch mal, was unsere äh Freunde von der NSA sich alles noch lustiges ähm haben einfallen lassen, denn bis zum Kongress denke ich mal,
Auch weiterhin wöchentlich Neuigkeiten absagen.
Ja, da wird's wird's weiterhin noch Sachen geben. Da sind ja auch schon ähm,
ja, jene, die sich da selber ein bisschen profilieren wollen in diesem Bereich, kündigen ja dann auch schon an, was da ist, Wandern, da werden ja noch ganz, ganz tolle Sachen rauskommen und so. Ich,
Ähm aber jetzt haben wir erstmal ähm diese schöne Nachricht, dass die NSA Handystandortdaten überwacht,
und zwar fünf Milliarden Standortdaten pro Tag in eine Datenbank pflegt,
Damit hunderte Millionen Menschen überwacht. Ähm.
Und das Analysen unterzieht, um Menschen herauszufinden, die gemeinsam reisen,
ja? Ähm ich weiß nicht, inwiefern ich das hier schon an an dieser Stelle mal erklärt hatte, so ein ähm,
Mobilfunknetz heißt ja nicht umsonst äh Zellular Network, weil es aus verschiedenen Zellen besteht, die ähm,
deren Standorte im Prinzip
bekannt sind grundsätzlich. Ja, wir erinnern uns daran, ähm dass die vor einigen Jahren oder wann das war, die iPhones damit negativ auffielen, dass sie die GPS
Daten, die sie haben, mit den Zelltower-Informationen mischen. Ähm um so,
sich schneller lokalisieren zu können. Das heißt, dass das man fragt sein sein iPhone, wo bist du? Und das iPhone guckt einfach erstmal, na ja, was höre ich im im Umkreis für WLANs und welche Funkzellen,
empfange ich. Die haben alle eine einzelne ID. Und damit hast du das schon relativ schnell sehr, sehr genau runtergebrochen, wo sich das Gerät befindet. Auf auf dem Planeten. Und,
Dann kann man.
Nur die iPhones, sondern das machen eigentlich alle.
Alle, machen alle Telefone so. Und ähm gleichzeitig hilft dir das wiederum, die die,
Die detaillierte Positionsbestimmung mittels GPAS zu beschleunigen, weil du nicht mit den, mit einer, mit einer,
nicht ohne Vorwissen in diesem Prozess gehst, sondern dann anhand der Uhrzeit errechnen kannst, welcher GPS-Satellit wahrscheinlich gerade über dir ist und auf welchen du gerade hören musst, um dann zu gucken, wo du bist, ja? Des deswegen macht man das.
Also es ist äh klar, Mobilfunknetze erlauben sehr gut, dass das Orten oder das das Bestimmen seiner Position,
ähm wenn man an der höheren Stelle ist, weil man sich eben selbst jungieren kann aufgrund der Signalstärken der verschiedenen Zellen. Gleichzeitig kann das Mobilfunknetzwerk und muss das Mobilfunknetzwerk zu jedem Zeitpunkt wissen, wo seine Nutzer sind,
leuchtet auch ein. Wenn man jetzt davon ausgeht, ich ich bin bei E plus
ne? Und E Plus bekommt einen Anruf für mich. Das heißt irgendwie bei also dieser Anruf kommt aus dem Festnetz, das heißt bei E Plus
geht auf einmal eine Lampe an, ey, hier ruft einer an für den Linus. Ja, dann muss E Plus dafür sorgen, dass mein Handy klingelt, ja? Sie wollen natürlich, sie würden ihr Netz überfrachten, wenn sie,
allen Mobilfunkzellen, allen Eplus Mobilfunktionen in Deutschland sagen würden.
Sendet mal bitte das Signal raus, dass Linus Handy gerade klingelt, ne, sondern sie wissen natürlich, dass ich,
also sie wissen, durch regelmäßige Kommunikation meines Telefones mit ihrem Netz, dass ich mich grob in Berlin befinde und lasse uns dann nur so in einem äh low,
Location Area Code oder sogar nur auf noch kleinerem Level in Berlin klingeln, um ähm mein Telefon darauf hinzuweisen, dass es jetzt bitte äh,
Also sie senden diesen Anruf für mich nur in einem lokal begrenzten Bereich aus, weil sie die ganze Zeit wissen, wo ich bin.
Ja, beziehungsweise lassen die ein eine gewisse Zahl an Basisstationen davon wissen und die, die dich dann auch wirklich sieht.
Genau, an die wird's dann durchgeschaltet.
Die grade sozusagen die Kommunikation macht, weil man ist ja im Prinzip die ganze Zeit verbunden. Also es ist ja, das ist so so eine Fehlwahrnehmung, dass man irgendwie nur dann sichtbar ist, wenn man telefoniert, das ist natürlich Quatsch.
Genau, nennt sich Location-Update. Das Telefon macht die ganze Zeit Location-Updates und sagt, ey, ich bin übrigens noch da. Ich bin jetzt an dieser Zelle. Ich bin jetzt in diesem LAC. Ähm,
gar keine ähm also es ist ein ein notwendiger Bestandteil der Funktion dieses dieses Mobilfunknetzes. Interessant wird das ähm,
Im Bereich der der SMS. Das ist äh etwas, was seit Jahren auch genutzt wird, ähm wofür wovor auch eigentlich schon seit längerer Zeit öffentlich gewarnt wird. Ähm,
dass man ein eine Information über den Aufenthaltsort eines Nutzers auch dann bekommen kann, wenn man nicht der Mobilfunk Provider ist.
Und zwar geht dieses System aus den ganzen Zellen, was der Mobilfunk weiter da jetzt irgendwie verwaltet, ja an irgendeiner Stelle, da dazu über, mit anderen Netzwerken verbunden zu werden, also mit,
Zum Beispiel,
oder mit einem Mobilfunk Provider in einem in einem anderen Land. Und dieses Netzwerk, was diese ganzen Mobilfunk Provider verbindet, nennt sich,
SS sieben,
System seven. Und auf das ist quasi so das das Backend der ähm der Mobilfunk Provider. Auf dem,
traurigerweise.
Nur der Mobilfunk Provider, sondern generell der Telefonie, Infrastruktur, also SS sieben ist so quasi was IP für das Internet ist, ist SS sieben für Telefonnetze,
Das ist die Sprache, die alle Telefonanbieter und alle Telefonvermittlungsstellen untereinander sprechen.
Und du hast da das also was du was du da für ein Problem hast, ist das dieses Netz ähm unter der Annahme,
organisch gewachsen ist, dass ihr nur als Telefonprovider dazu Zugang bekommt. Und SS sieben ähm ist,
leider hat einfach im Prinzip keine großartigen Sicherheits äh Vorkehrungen. Ähm die.
Das ist ja eine exklusive Club und wenn man irgendwie in den Salon kommt, dann äh ja, ist ja schon mal vorne durch den Eingang gegangen und da kommen ja nur Leute im Anzug rein. Genau. Die Zeiten sind aber schon lange vorbei.
Na ja, es geht noch weiter. Die noch dazu sind dann die Provider dazu übergegangen, weil dieses SS sieben Protokoll gleichzeitig ihnen ein bisschen zu äh die die Vendoren, also die Hersteller von Equipment, da.
Ventoren.
Die Wenders. Ich nenne es halt Vendon. So die,
die Hersteller von dem Equipment sind dazu übergegangen, dass sie gesagt haben, na ja, dieses SS sieben ähm das Protokoll selber ist ja so ein bisschen,
eingeschränkt in seiner Nutzbarkeit, dann machen wir doch mal noch so ein paar probiertäre Erweiterungen des SS sieben Protokolls, damit wir zum Beispiel eine Fernwartung unternehmen können unser Gerät und so, ja?
Da hat zum Beispiel der äh Philip äh französischer Sicherheitsforscher, äh der sich seit Jahren damit auseinandersetzt, äh mit Angriffen
auf Infrastruktur, über SS sieben. Macht dann so schöne Sachen wie das Home Location, irgendwie platt zu machen, also quasi den zentralen
zentrale Datenbank eines Mobilfunknetzes zu dass das ganze Netz ausfällt und ähnliche Geschichten.
Der entscheidende Punkt ist, was ist in SS sieben in der Regel nicht gibt, ist eine Prüfung, ob eine Anfrage äh legitim ist oder nicht,
Und was jetzt passiert, ähm wenn ich aus ähm.
Ähm machen wir als Beispiel, weil wir gerade Philipp hat, einen Philipp aus Frankreich, schickt mir eine SMS. So, dann schreibt er an, schreibt der in seinem,
schreib in seinem Handy eine SMS. Diese SMS geht an das SMSC von seinem von seinem Mobilfunk Provider,
dieser Mobilfunk Provider fragt dann bei meinem,
Äh Anbieter in Deutschland E Plus nach und sagt, ey, ich habe hier eine SMS für,
so und so für den Linus. Ähm schickt mir doch mal die Routing Information. Damit ich die über die Zelle, wo der Linus gerade ist, einfach direkt zustellen kann. Und E Plus antwortet dann mit ähm,
einer äh Location-Information, eben dem in der Regel dem LAC so auf dem Level. Äh wohin,
Frankreich, der französische Provider dann diese SMS schicken kann. Und wenn sich der französische Provider dann entscheiden sollte, diese SMS einfach nicht zu schicken,
sondern nur das Kommando SAI, SMS Info vor Short Message SRISM ohne das S. Info for Short Message, dann kann also ein französischer Provider,
Ähm die ganze Zeit meinen Provider fragen, wo ich denn gerade bin.
Und ähm man könnte das jetzt natürlich also die äh sinnvolle Möglichkeit ist natürlich, also es gibt natürlich eine offensichtliche Möglichkeit, das abzuschalten, indem man so ein Proxi dazwischen schaltet. Das Entscheidende ist, ähm,
diesem Kommando kann man weltweit,
vom Schreibtisch aus Personen tracken und das wird als seit Jahren, als Dienstleistung angeboten im Internet. Kostet dann irgendwie so irgendwie null Komma eins Cent oder ein Cent pro Abfrage. Kann man so im Hunderter- oder Tausender-Pack
äh kaufen, gibt's eine Telefonnummer an, sagt der dir, wo die Person ist.
Und wenn das dann in so einer ländlichen Region ist, dann ist die Auflösung ein bisschen geringer. Wenn's in einer äh urbanen Region ist, dann wird die Auflösung natürlich sehr viel kleiner. So,
Das ist ein Kommando, was da benutzt wird. Es gibt noch weitere SS sieben Kommandos, die auch äh Location-Informationen enthalten, zum Beispiel
den und so weiter. Und natürlich auch wenn die Nutzer einen Location-Update machen und gerade Roman,
Also ich bin in Frankreich, ich bin gerade bei Philipp zu Besuch zum Beispiel und dann sagt mein Handy die ganze Zeit den den in den französischen Zellen hier bin ich, hier bin ich, hier bin ich. Und diese Information geht natürlich dann auch über SS sieben zu meinem Provider Eplus.
Und in diesem SS sieben Netzwerk, in dem alle einander vertrauen, nichts großartig verschlüsselt wird,
Und die ganze Zeit Location, Informationen hin und her gehen, da hängt die NSA drin und nimmt da einfach mal fünf Milliarden Standortdaten pro Tag raus.
Fünf Milliarden Standortdaten von Telefon. Zur Erinnerung, Weltbevölkerung, gerade sieben Milliarden.
Interessanter ist eher, wie viele äh wie wie viele ähm Handys äh betroffen sind, ne? Und sie sagen, das wären hunderte Millionen, ja. Also es sind trotzdem immer noch von jeder betroffenen Person Unmengen an.
Ach so, sie meinen mit diesen mit diesen fünf Milliarden sind sozusagen die Samples gemeint, also sie nehmen fünf Milliarden mal ein ein Sample von einer Location, das sind nicht fünf Milliarden,
Ich meine, so viele sind doch überhaupt gar nicht im Betrieb, oder? Hunderte, Millionen von Geräten. Also es gibt schon so ein paar, für die sie sich nicht so interessieren.
Ja, äh sie sagen, dass sie äh dass sie äh US-Amerikaner natürlich ausschließen, aber aufgrund ihres Designes,
verhindern können, dass eine, dass eine signifikante Anteil US-amerikaner dabei ist. Und das ist natürlich ein bisschen interessant, weil was ich jetzt gerade, also was was mich jetzt ähm ein bisschen beschäftigt ist, also sie können,
Wie ich gerade schon gesagt habe, aktiv mit diesen Kommandos auch gezielt eine Person tracken. Ähm,
Aber die Menge an Informationen, die sie ja bekommen, lässt nur den Schlüssel zu, dass sie das passiv machen oder auch passiv. Ja, also ich glaube, dass sie's also vermutlich machen sie es aktiv und passiv,
Das heißt, die schlorcheln einfach an mehreren Stellen weltweit das SS sieben mit,
und ähm sie proben offensichtlich dann auch oder offenbar auch Einzelpersonen dann aktiv, ne. Weil ja auch niemand diese SS sieben lockt oder untersucht. Ähm und mir wird auch so erzählt, dass ähm wenn man sich in,
Mobilfunk Providern mit dem SS sieben auseinandersetzt. Äh dass man da relativ schnell an Leute geht, die sagen, ach da brauchen nicht zu gucken.
Wird weitergehen.
Ähm da solche solche Gerüchte ähm hört man dann immer wieder, ja? Ähm,
Was mich allerdings ein bisschen wundert, ist, dass das ja alles dann voraussetzen würde, dass sie ins SSS, dass sie dass die Transaktion, die sie mitniffen, durchs SS sieben geht,
das sollte eigentlich nicht der Fall sein beim größeren Teil der Transaktion. Also bei Linus läuft durch Berlin,
Natürlich gibt's die ganze Zeit Location-Updates, ähm die dann mit meinem Netzwerkbetreiber gemacht werden. Es gibt aber nach meinem Verständnis keinen Grund, warum diese das SS sieben Netz äh berühren sollten.
Ja, also warum sollte das, ich meine, ist eine Information, die eigentlich äh E plus nicht äh anderen Netzen mitteilen muss, solange sie nicht danach fragen,
äh sodass das nur zulässt, dass entweder mein Provider dann aktiv wird, also,
oder so was kommen und beantwortet werden,
oder dass die NSA noch weiter in diese Infrastruktur vorgedrungen ist und zum Beispiel dann direkt die ganzen HLASQ hat. Und das ist so ein bisschen die,
das, was ich denke, was unausgesprochen hier noch ähm,
Im Raume steht, weil du sonst vermutlich nicht auf die Zahlen kommst. Und sie das auch gesagt hätten, dass das hauptsächlich Roaming-Nutzer betreffen würde und das haben sie ja nicht.
Hm
Na, also wie sie's wie sie auf diese Zahlen kommen,
denke ich, erstens nur durch auf jeden Fall durch mehrere Stationen, an denen sie das Niffing machen. Ähm,
eventuell so, dass sie das das intern die Infrastruktur natürlich auch SS sieben spricht und sie da noch irgendwie dranhängen,
Ähm das könnte die Antwort sein, aber auf jeden Fall müssen sie an sehr vielen Stationen.
Ja, aber,
nicht eigentlich schon ausreichend, dass sie einfach ein gleichberechtigter Teilnehmer sind. Ich meine, diese diese Dienstleistungen, die du da angesprochen hast. Ich meine, das sind kleine Buden gegebenenfalls sogar äh ein Mann, ein Frauenunternehmen
die sich da halt Zugang verschaffen, die so einen Virtual Provider sind und äh ne, so quasi wie so ein Handykarten äh äh Reeseler, aber ich,
Soweit muss man's doch gar nicht mal treiben, um da einen entsprechenden Status zu bekommen, weil wenn man halt irgendwie nachweist, dass man da äh Dienstleistungen anbietet, irgend welcher Form
ist man da halt einfach mit äh dabei und das ist natürlich für die NSA nun überhaupt gar kein äh Problem, diesen Status im Telefonnetz zu erreichen. Also.
Ja ja, nee, ist also gar keine.
Dann halt einfach da, also.
Ich denk, also für mich geht's um die Mischung aus aktiv und passiv. Die sind sowieso da drin, klar.
Sie werden auch einfach eine signifikante signifikanten Teil einfach mit sniffen, ja? Das steht außer Frage. Das heißt, sie nutzen auch einfach viel von dem Verkehr, der einfach ohnehin unter SS sieben stattfindet.
Die Frage ist, an wie vielen Stationen müssen sie sitzen? Um auf diese Zahl zu kommen.
Du meinst nicht, dass sie jetzt wirklich alle diese Telefone äh explizit mit SRI, SM oder sowas hinterfraß würde wahrscheinlich auch fallen.
Das ähm
glaube ich, das können sie sich nicht leisten. Sie sie haben ja sogar schon Schwierigkeiten, diese fünf Milliarden Standortdaten pro Tag zu verarbeiten. Also sie sprechen explizit von Speicher und Verarbeitungsproblemen,
und ähm wenn sie gleichzeitig noch die Infrastruktur hätten, um die alle zu senden, da würden sie dann auch in so einem SS sieben äh noch.
Ich meine, hängen sie wahrscheinlich genauso auf den äh Glasfaserkabeln wieder, wie beim Internetverbindungen auch, ob da nun SS sieben oder IP darüber gesprochen wird, das sind an der Stelle wahrscheinlich herzlich egal.
So sieht es vermutlich aus. In der also SS sieben wird dann eh häufig auch in in IP gekapselt irgendwo. Also sieht schlecht aus für unsere Handys.
Frage ist natürlich, was machen jetzt eigentlich die die Telekom-Unternehmen? Ich meine, es gab ja jetzt, hier werden ein schönes Interview, Rene Obermann, der irgendwie sich äh mittlerweile irgendwie empört et cetera
und äh man hat ja auch immer so, es liegt ja so ein bisschen die Unterstellung auch im Raum, dass die das einfach mit sich geschehen lassen, nach dem Motto, na ja, ist ja der Staat und was kann
machen und Hauptsache wir kriegen unsere Aufträge und passt schon.
Ja, also so scheint ja die Haltung zu sein. Es gibt es gibt einige äh Netzbetreiber, die zumindest etwas gegen dieses
allen allen Nutzern zur Verfügung stehende äh SRISM äh Tracking machen,
Und das ist eben ein ein Proxi dazwischen schalten. Das heißt, sie ruhten die ganzen SMS nochmal einmal durch so ein SMS-Proxi. Hat auch Vorteile, um bestimmte Angriffe, die bei SMS stattfinden, auch direkt mit rauszufiltern.
Aber ähm das machen bisher nur wenige,
Netzanbieter. Und ich denke auch nicht, dass die äh dass die NSA das über diese doch relativ plumpe,
Methode macht. Ich denke, sie gucken sich eher die Location-Updates an. Und ähm ja, also meine Vermutung ist,
Sie hören viel passiv, sie machen ein bisschen aktiv, das Passiv machen sie an vielen Stellen und ähm,
steht natürlich noch so die die Verschwörungstheorie im Raum
dass sie oder dass sie unter Umständen auch dieses Equipment einfach haben, ja, dass sie also noch nicht mal wirklich mehr auf dem SS sieben sitzen, sondern eben im Herzen des Mobilfunknetzes selber dann im im ALA.
Und ähm das wäre dann so etwas, was äh,
was Philipp äh zum Beispiel äh auch regelmäßig dann zeigt, ja, an ähm,
Dass es gibt in in diese HLAs rein und so. Und berichtet dann irgendwie von Schwierigkeiten, dass die Hersteller irgendwie gar nicht so großes Interesse haben, diese Schwachstellen zu fixen und so,
Naja, also äh eure wir werden die NSA überwacht weltweit die Bewegungen der Personen und das mit einem Gesetz von Ronald Dragon von neunzehnhunderteinundachtzig. Alles legal, cool, oder?
Mhm, super.
Dann gab's noch eine kleine Anmeldung am Rande, nur weil ich ja jetzt auch letztens das äh ähm über diesen Stern-TV-Beitrag mit äh Handy abschnüffeln haben. Ähm,
Die Telekom hat jetzt zum wiederholten Male, muss man sagen, angekündigt, dass sie bis zum Ende des Jahres die eine äh verbesserte Verschlüsselung äh Chiffre einführen wollen in ihre GSM-Netze,
nämlich die Verschlüsselung von drei G App, dann bei GSM nutzen wollen und das wäre,
signifikante Verbesserung Ihres Schutzes gegen das äh gegen das Abhören gegen das passive Abhören.
Also die Verschlüsselung von drei G, also in,
im UMTS Standard, die dort übliche Verschlüsselung auch auf das GSM, das alte Netzwerk zu übertragen. Genau. Technisches, das dann konkret, welche.
A5 drei heißt die.
A53, also A fünf ist sehr ursprünglich äh A fünf eins ist sozusagen der ursprüngliche Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus, dem mittlerweile viele Schwächen nachgewiesen sind und bei A fünf drei ist es wie.
Ist es ein komplett neu, also ist ein ein ganz anderer äh äh eine ganz andere Schiffe, die eigentlich Kasumi heißt,
anders funktioniert und gegen die bisher nur einige theoretische Angriffe bekannt sind, die für die es keine praktische.
Aber können das auch alle Telefone.
Ähm das können alle Telefone, die auch äh drei G können, haben grundsätzlich die Möglichkeit, auf
GSM dann diese neue Schiffe anzuwenden, ganz alte Telefone nicht. Und es gab ein größeres Problem mit bestimmten
Telefon, die eine Fehlimplementierung hatten
äh A fünf drei auf GSM zu sprechen. Und das hat äh das Ausrollen auch so lange verzögert, weil es eben eine,
nennenswert vertretene Anzahl an Telefonen gibt
von einem großen Hersteller die Probleme damit hat A fünf drei auf GSM zu sprechen und deswegen dieses Update nicht mitgemacht hat. Man muss sich also vorstellen, das Netz geht dann hin, erkennt an der von dem Telefon, okay, mit dem kann ich,
auch A fünf drei sprechen und bietet das dann an und dann sprechen sie auf fünf drei und bei bestimmten Telefonen, obwohl sie eigentlich A fünf drei können
hatten eine Fehlimplementierung und die hat dann dazu geführt, dass diese Telefone nicht mehr funktionierten, wenn A fünf drei aktiviert war und deswegen hat sich das so lange hingezogen.
Diese Information, um welche Telefon es sich dabei handelt, äh oder welchem Hersteller es jetzt nicht öffentlich.
Ich bin, hoffentlich habe ich noch nicht zu viel erzählt. Also, es, die, die Information ist sicherlich nicht öffentlich,
Aber ähm das waren ein großer Hersteller,
mit telefon, die relativ verkauft waren. Und da hatten die Hersteller eben jetzt ein Jahr Probleme mit. Deswegen hat sich das ein bisschen ähm äh rausgezögert.
Und das machen hat auch angekündigt wo davon bis März nächsten Jahres und ähm ja auch in anderen Ländern beobachtet man das jetzt schon so. Dass das jetzt langsam kommt. Die das Ausrollen von A fünf drei.
Zeit wird's.
Ja, aber interessanterweise, ne, so wenn einmal auf einmal das Kanzlerinnenhandy abgehört wird, dann äh muss das auf einmal alles ganz schnell gehen, so. Auf der Seite GSM Map fordern wir das inzwischen seit vielen Jahren.
Na gut, das ist also das äh die Abhörrealität in der in der echten Welt so, aber Gott sei Dank haben wir ja noch unsere Spiele, in die wir uns zurückziehen können. Da will ja keiner was von uns, stimmt.
Ja, wir können second live und World of Warcraft können wir uns rein.
Da ist alles schön irgendwie laufen nur
Wunderhübsche Menschen herum und man äh ist die ganze Zeit in einem Zauber äh umgeben und äh alles ist romantisch und äh erotisch und äh spannend und
lenkt ab und von den Sorgen des Alltags.
Ja, das ist eigentlich nur eine Kurzmeldung. NSA und GCHQ ähm,
schnorcheln auch Daten aus äh Multiplayer Spielewelten äh wie zum Beispiel Xbox live äh World of Warcraft und wie ist das andere?
Ich ich.
Mhm. Xbox live. Xbox live. Mhm.
Xbox live. Äh wo dann, also das Messefliegen Multiplayer, Online Rollplaying Games heißt das. Ne, gibt's eine da habe ich ja noch drüber gelacht. Da gibt's ja einen CRE zu, ne, von von Dennis. World of Warcraft oder so heißt der. Ähm,
Ja, also man muss sich das so überlegen, ne. Diese, also ich glaube, die die Idee war ja, dass diese MMO RPGs ähm,
haben, ne, dass Leute mit einem Headset sich da an ihren Computer setzen,
völlig beknackt natürlich sich mit dem Headset am Computer zu setzen. Und sich unterhalten ähm und das dann über diese über diese Spielewelten tun können. Und der der nicht so blöd die nicht so blöde Idee ist ja, dass ich als Terrorist dann da quasi einen Anschlag spielen,
Planen könnte. Innerhalb dieser Welt. Ja und dadurch quasi äh.
Lernt, wie man sich dann abstimmt, um irgendwie ein.
Ja oder einfach so mich unterhalten kann über äh über Waffen und Schwerter und äh Pläne schmieden kann und das eben in dieser in dieser Orkwelt nicht auffällt. Und die NSA hat sich gedacht, ey, in diesem World of Warcraft darin Orks rum,
Feen? Dann sind ja bestimmt auch Terroristen.
Ich ich sehe schon vor meinem geistigen Auge so die Terrorismusanklagen äh der Zukunft, ja. Ja, sie haben sich doch in diesem Netzwerk getroffen, ja. Sie haben doch einen Anschlag auf die Eisprinzessin äh geplant.
Genau. Wir haben ja hier den.
Wir haben doch hier den Mitschnitt, wie sie sich mit ihren, ja, also, ich meine, das das hat doch alles real realen Bezug.
Alle sitzen nur mit offenen Mündern da und denken sich, oh mein Gott. Sie haben den Verstand verloren.
Das haben sie offenbar, ja.
Das ist echt wirklich unfassbar. Na ja.
Dann, ja, wir kommen jetzt noch so zu kleinen,
Vorkommnissen, die ich aber trotzdem auch irgendwie die Erwähnung finden müssen. Ähm der Chefredakteur des Guardian, äh Ellen Russbridger, musste dann im britischen Innenausschuss,
Patriotismustest machen, ne? Hast du gesehen, oder?
Hast du gesehen? Ich hab's nicht gesehen, ich habe nur gehört davon.
Unglaublich. Unglaublich. Also da, das verlinken wir einfach mal nur das Video. Da kann man sich anschauen, wie der Russer da in diesem Innenausschuss sitzt. Das scheint die scheinen ähnlich gut drauf zu sein, wie der deutsche Innenausschuss des Bundestages.
Ähm wo sie ihn dann ernsthaft fragen, ob er ein Patriot sei.
Das ist geil, das ist auch wichtig, das ist sozusagen so ein, so ein Status, den man sich erarbeiten äh muss und sonst darf man auch keine Zeitung rausgeben.
Das Gesicht, was der Mann macht, als ihm die Frage gestellt wird, ist unbezahlbar. Also äh ernsthafte Empfehlung, sich äh das Video mal anzuschauen. In die Home Affairs Comedy. Ähm,
Dann gab es noch was Schönes, äh Sigmar Gabriel, also Sigmar Gabriel, ähm ist ja jetzt wirklich so der sammelt ja gerade richtig Punkte.
Oh ja, muss er ja auch.
Also was hat was geht jetzt bei dem auf die Kappe? Alles seid ihr alles seit der Bundestagswahl? Es geht ja irgendwie zu den Jusos und sagt ähm Erika Steinbach will ja keine Rechte, ja?
Keine Rassistin.
Ach so, was auch immer er da gesagt hat. Ja, also ähm.
Äh äh er will äh kenne keine Rassisten bei der CDU. Das war, glaube ich, die Aussage.
Undenkbar. Ähm kann ich, kann ich nicht genau sagen. Als sie auf jeden Fall mit den Jusos angelegt, so was interessiert mich dann, hat er sich mit der,
Karin Slomka im ZDF angelegt, wobei ich sagen muss, das fand ich jetzt nicht besonders nennenswert. Also das war nicht besonders
Es gab, es gab ja ein großes äh großen Aufstand darum, dass er der Frau gesagt hat, jetzt lassen sie mal den Quatsch hier sein, ja?
Mariata äh Slomka heißt sie.
Oh, weil hier wäre ich sehr genannt. Heißt sie nicht.
Mariata Slomka. Ja wobei.
Karin, äh.
Wobei ich sagen muss an der Stelle ähm konnte ich ihre Argumentationslinie auch wirklich nicht,
äh nachvollziehen, also äh
sozusagen der SPD vorzuwerfen, dass sie ihre Mitglieder befragt und das Ganze als undemokratisch äh hinzustellen. Das ist schon wirklich auch eine eine Gedankenbrücke, die muss man erstmal gebaut bekommen. Also da da steige ich dann doch auch aus
und äh da nehme ich äh Sigmar Gabriel seine seine entgeisterte äh Reaktion hoch voll ab, so.
Absolut richtig, zumal diese Frau ja dann oft
ähm mehrmals diese Frage einfach nur wiederholt hat. Und ähm das kann man ja dann nicht als, also das kann man ja nicht ernsthaft weiter als als kritischen Journalismus äh
kaufen, ja? Wenn sie, wenn sie eine Frage stellt, er beantwortet die und sagt, nee, also Entschuldigung, nehme ich die Frage, nehme ich den Vorwurf nehme ich nicht ernst?
Argument und sie sagt, ja aber,
und er sagt dann irgendwann komm, lassen Sie uns den Quatsch jetzt mal beenden. Ja, also Entschuldigung, da würde ich mir an anderer Stelle sehr viel äh bissigeren Journalismus wünschen ähm und jetzt nicht diesen Auftritt von der Maria, Mariette.
Mariata.
Mariatta, an der Stelle jetzt besonders ähm,
Besonders würdigen, aber hat auch nicht zu seinem äh Vorteil gewirkt, denn das hat, da haben sich, haben sich irgendwie die Medien drei Tage mit auseinandergesetzt. Dann haben sie in der Bildzeitung eine Anzeige geschaltet für den Mitgliederentscheid zu stimmen,
man ausgerechnet hat, wenn das irgendwie,
Diese Anzeige hat ungefähr pro SPD Mitglied knappen Euro gekostet pro Stimmen stimmberechtigt, SPD-Mitglied.
Ja, ich meine, das ist eh alles eine Farce, auch in den Unterlagen, die sie äh verschicken, werben Sie halt aktiv für ein Jahr. Das geht eigentlich auch nicht. Also, ich meine, entweder man fragt da und äh lässt eine,
eine freie Entscheidung zu oder oder nicht und das ist es nicht. Aber was ich noch ein bisschen fragwürdiger finde
ist das, worauf du jetzt wahrscheinlich eilig anspielst, nämlich seine Ausführung zum Thema
Vorratsdatenspeicherung, die äh SPD muss ja jetzt in dem Rahmen der großen Koalition das jetzt wieder ganz toll finden, so richtig verabschiedet hat sie sich ja äh nie davon. Wir hatten das ja hier auch schon so die internen äh Querelen. Der Versuch, über die SPD-Parteiträger Tage der SPD da eine Linie zu verpassen, im Sinne von
Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Wollen wir nicht. Das wurde dann schon allein über diese ähm wie heißt nochmal gleich, diese Ausschüsse, die vom Parteitag das eigentliche Programm,
Programmkomitees oder so äh
Also das wurde sozusagen schon soweit abgeschwächt, dass am Ende halt nur bei so einem Vorstandsbeschluss abgestimmt wurde und nicht über die eigentliche Basisinitiative, in der halt dann gesagt wurde, so, naja, so äh,
Man muss da hinwirken, dass irgendwie alles nicht so schlimm wird und na ja, genau mit diesem Kompromiss sind sie jetzt quasi ja auch in die
Koalitionsverhandlungen gegangen und da steht da letzten Endes wieder drin, das ist halt so dieses,
Vorratsdatenspeicherung äh schmeckt auf einmal nach äh Erdbeere, wenn's die nur drei Monate lang äh ist und kann ja alles nicht so schlimm sein.
Und sie wollen sie ja trotzdem machen. Also und sie wollen sechs Monate machen.
Ja, weil sie ist ja auch super effizient
ja, wie dann Herr Gabriel auch ausgeführt hatte, weil äh man sieht das ja, man hätte ja dann zum Beispiel bei dem Terrorismusanschlag von Anders Breiweg in Norwegen ja gesehen, wie großartig das äh funktioniert hat. Da hätte man ihn ja halt ausfindig gemacht.
Nee, er hat, er hat schon gesagt, man hat man wusste sehr schnell,
Ja, das stimmt, wer er war und dass er alleine war, das hätte sehr geholfen. So, das jetzt, jetzt, das ist so perfide auf so vielen Ebenen. Diese, diese Gruppe, Jugendgruppe, die sich auf der Insel Uth Utaja da getroffen hat, das waren ja Sozialdemokraten, ne?
Weil diese sozialdemokratische Jugendorganisation. Also jetzt nimmt der den Mord an diesen Menschen,
Also das ein Akument, was also auf jeden Fall bei der SPD-Basis sitzen sollte, ne, wollt ihr nicht. Ihr wollt doch auch, dass keine Terroristen unsere Jugendcamps angreifen, unsere Jusos,
und stellt sich raus, äh Norwegen hatte zu dem Zeitpunkt keine Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Also vielleicht hatten sie eine eine inoffizielle Vorratsdatenspeicherung, äh wo sie diese Daten dann hergeholt haben. Ja, nur um ihn irgendwie ausfindig zu machen und zu wissen, wer er war. Ich meine, äh
war da alleine auf einer Insel mit all den Kindern und hat sie irgendwie äh erschossen äh,
Das haben sie dann schon mitbekommen und da mussten sie nur hinfahren, da braucht's jetzt auch keine Vorratsdatenspeicherung, um da vorzeitig äh äh dagegen vorzugehen. Also das ist wirklich albern.
Also man muss sich auch mal, also ich, man muss sich erst mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen, ja. Das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat diese vor Jahren abgeschmettert,
wir haben die gesamte Debatte geführt, wir haben,
eigentlich ein Konsens. Wir haben Personen selbst in seiner eigenen Partei, die massiv gegen diese Vorhaben sind. Wir haben Überwachungsskandal der NSA, seit seit Monaten hier toben. Wo nur,
jeden Tag nur Missbrauch von Daten äh ans Licht getragen wird. Und das einzige Argument, was dem Mann,
einfällt,
ist dann auch noch ein ein einfachen, ein unsachliches, was, wo man wirklich in Frage stellen muss, ob er so schlecht informiert war, dass er das nicht vorher wusste, dass er da einfach nur einen Mist erzählt.
Ja, ist schon ein bisschen haarig.
Das finde ich schon wirklich ähm bezeichnend.
Wir prallen das an. Oder? Wir prallen.
Wir prangern das an, solange wir dürfen,
Dann gab's äh jetzt dann doch nach den vielen Monaten ähm einen,
Protest gegen die NSA Überwachung auch aus dem wirtschaftlichen Bereich, wo also jetzt äh in den USA, glaube ich, AOL, Microsoft Facebook, Google, LinkedIn und Yahoo eine Website gemacht haben
reform Governments.
Apple ist, glaube ich, auch mit dabei, ne, in dieser Initiative.
Das kann sein. Ich habe jetzt, das sollte jetzt nicht eine, nee, sehe ich nicht. Twitter.
Nee. Nee, stimmt. Ach so, okay, bei dieser Webseite, Reform, okay, alles klar.
Also da haben sie jetzt natürlich so eine haben sie eine lange äh eine haben sie einen offenen Brief verfasst, Apple, da ist Apple dabei, bei dem offenen Brief. Erstaunlicherweise oben nicht.
Haben sie einen einen offenen Brief verfasst und äh verschiedene Prinzipien jetzt da formuliert, äh wie denn die Überwachung
zu regeln sei durch die Regierungen
ja es ist zu begrüßen, war aber auch von auszugehen, dass sie es früher später tun würden, weil sie inzwischen nach so vielen Monaten selbstverständlich äh international ähm,
im internationalen Markt internationalen Markt Probleme haben gegenüber den anderen Anbietern, die natürlich genauso mit ihren jeweiligen Geheimdiensten äh zusammenarbeiten,
Aber äh da jetzt gerade nicht so für am Pranger stehen, ne. Also Deutsche äh soziale Netzwerke werben ja jetzt schon irgendwie mit äh Datenschutz made in Germany und so wie ich äh.
Aber das ist schon, das ist schon ganz schön peinlich, muss ich sagen für die amerikanische Regierung und ich glaube auch nicht, dass das jetzt so äh folgenlos sein kann, weil wir wissen ja, Politik äh ist in den USA schon immer, nicht nur dort, aber,
vor allem auch da äh sehr getragen gewesen durch,
die Wirtschaft. So und äh über lange, lange Zeit war halt die Wirtschaft vor allem,
Autoindustrie, Industrie im weiteren Sinne, militärischer Komplex und all das, da sind die großen Summen äh bewegt worden und natürlich Energie, Entschuldigung, habe ich ganz vergessen.
Bewegen auch immer noch eine ganze Menge Geld, aber mittlerweile äh ja das größte Unternehmen ist Apple und die komplette,
Digitalbranche ist einfach die
Zukunftsindustrie der Amerikaner schlechthin und die Ausbreitung der Dienste über das über die Welt, an der ja sagen wir mal auch die NSA selber in gewisser Hinsicht ein Interesse daran hat, weil es ihnen natürlich auch den Zugriff hintenrum äh in gewisser Hinsicht schon wieder einfacher macht, dass,
schlägt jetzt einfach äh zurück, weil sich halt alle fragen, äh warum soll ich meine Daten hier in einer US-Cloud äh reinwerfen, wenn die alle so böse zu mir sind?
Und das ist natürlich ein PR-Desaster allererster Größenordnung, was jetzt nicht nur eine einzelnen Firma schadet, sondern was einfach generell gegen,
Technik aus den USA geht und daran kann dieses Land kein Interesse haben
und äh dass die so in sich doch relativ verfeindeten Unternehmen, die hier genannt wurden, äh jetzt da gemeinsam vorgehen, ist auch schon mal ein ganz interessantes Signal, weil die könnten ja nun alle untereinander sich kaum mehr bekriegen,
Google, äh Apple und Facebook et cetera kennen das alles. Und jetzt äh treten die mit so einem offenen Brief auf, also.
Ich sage nicht, dass es jetzt die Revolution, aber das ist schon mal sehr interessant, dass es überhaupt so weit gekommen ist, weil dieses sind sie denn eigentlich Patrioten? Ich glaube, mit dem kann jetzt irgendwie keiner kommen, weil dann gehen die nämlich eigentlich äh,
dieselbe Ebene zurück und sagen, ja wie ist denn mit euch eigentlich, dass ihr hier äh der amerikanischen Gesellschaft so großen Schaden zuführt da durch eure nachlässigen Umgang mit äh Gesetzen und,
Ethik und was nicht alles hier noch eine Rolle spielt,
Das wäre auch mal überhaupt eine interessante Frage an die an die Politiker, die das Ganze so machen. Ja, also ob sie denn irgendwie Patrioten sind. Weil letzten Endes schaden wir ja auch unserer Gesellschaft, durch unser Verhalten.
Würden einfach sagen, wenn der Snowden uns da nicht verraten hätte, dann hätte wäre der ja auch kein Schaden entstanden.
Ja tolle Argumentation.
Sind sie Patriot oder nicht?
Naja, Frau Merkel, sind sie Patriotin oder nicht?
Na ja. Bitcom.
Na ja. Hat's doch schön auf den Punkt gebracht, ja? Angela Merkel äh empört darüber, dass sie behandelt wird, wie ein deutscher Bürger.
Unglaublich. So weit ist es gekommen.
Ja, also soweit ist es schon gekommen.
Der Bitcom unterstützt die äh Initiative und in Deutschland äh äußerten sich dann auch noch ein paar,
DDR-Bürgerrechtler, die einfach mal das Ganze in ihre historische Perspektive äh gerückt
haben, was auch ganz interessant ist. Es kursiert darüber hinaus und da möchte ich jetzt mal ganz kurz mich drüber beklagen. Es kursiert darüber hinaus eine ähm,
Geht was rum von Change Dot ORG. Ähm.
Plattform für vor allem so links orientierte Petitionen et cetera.
Demokratie verteidigen im digitalen Zeitalter, ja? Ähm jetzt Aufruf zeichnet diese Kampagne wurde gerade neu auf Change dot org gestartet und wir denken, das könnte sie interessieren. Ich habe da wohl irgendwann mal was bei denen unterzeichnet,
habe dann da jetzt auch wieder, weil letztens irgendwas gegen Überwachung, habe ich gedacht, ach ja ach ja, gegen Vorratszeitenspeicherung, habe ich gesagt, dann,
Petitioniere ich da mal mit? Das sind ja so, ja, wie wie funktionieren die die? Die sammeln halt E-Mail-Adressen, äh schicken da E-Mails hin, äh machen so One-Click-Petitionen,
und schreiben dann am Ende hin ja hier hunderttausend Leute finden auch. Äh wir haben hunderttausend Leute gefragt und ähm,
Das ist ja eigentlich auch ganz schön, also ist ja ganz nett, dass sie es machen. Ich war aber dann bei Change und org sehr stark überrascht, als ich fertig war, dass sie mir anboten, ich könnte doch Werbung für diese Petition auf der change dot org Startseite,
kaufen. Ja,
Und zwar boten sie mir einige im Jahr so dreihundertdreihundert Leuten wird diese Werbung gezeigt, wenn du weiß ich, zwanzig Euro bezahlst.
Da habe ich nur meine Augenbraue hochgezogen und habe mir gedacht, na, dann werden die wohl bald wieder von mir so ein Auskunftsersuchen bekommen, welche Daten sie über mich gespeichert haben, dass sie die bitte löschen, mir die Löschung bestätigen. Mit so einer Firma, also was haben die denn?
Bescheuert, mit ihrer komischen Webseite da. Ich meine, das ist doch äh.
Also ihr Businessmodell ist, dass sie den Leuten, die da potenziell den Petition unterstützen würden, dann quasi die Werbung dafür bezahlen lassen. Interessantes.
Also ich meine, die haben ja wohl vollkommen schlecht geraucht. Das ist ja absolut nicht akzeptabel. Also brauchen wir nicht länger drüber zu reden, so. Also da die,
Unglaublich. So, also Change dot org, ihr habt ja wohl mal einen Knall. So, dann ähm kommen wir zum letzten Thema. Das habe ich, das letzte Thema habe ich mitgebracht,
nur ganz kurz ist das.
Das Netz.
Das Netz, der Jahresrückblick-Netz für Tick zwanzig dreizehn, zwanzig vierzehn äh erschienen im Berliner Verlags Media, unsere Freunde, die auch irids Info machen, Philipp Otto als Herausgeber, der auch bei uns schon mal,
Gast war, das sollte als Disclaimer reichen. Ähm das ist ein.
Nicht mitgeschrieben.
Ich habe nicht mitgeschickt. Ich bin beleidigt, die haben mich nicht gefragt.
Aha. Na ja, ich meine, warst du was mit zu tun mit dem Thema.
Netz? Nee, ich habe keine Ahnung. Vom Netz. Nee, also ich ich kann zu Recht beleidigt sein. Erstens äh wurde ich nicht gefragt. Zweitens, ist so das Thema, was ich eindeutig dieses Jahr äh beackert habe, diese ganze D-Makram darin auch nicht vertreten.
Ne, weil wohl da ist irgendwie, nee, also habe ich nicht den Eindruck, ich hab's aber auch noch nicht durchgelesen. Dafür, also mit diesem Mangel ausgezeichnet, ist dieses Heft,
Sehr schön gelungen. Es war ja schon letztes Jahr ein äh als sehr äh angenehm gestaltetes Heft und ist dieses Jahr,
noch noch schöner gelungen, muss, muss ich echt sagen. Kommt so in Hochglanz,
hat ähm Artikel von dem von mir so sehr hochgeschätzten Kai Biermann äh Monika Ermert von Heise äh Torsten Kleins,
Dirk Kreuzer, Konstanze kurz, Sascha Lobo, ähm Stefan Liegemeier. Also da sind,
gute Leute, Brust Schneider ist sogar ein übersetzter Artikel von drin sehr viele Leute die irgendwie so in der,
In dem in dem netzpolitischen Bereich sich geäußert haben. Ähm.
Und da in der Regel so versucht haben, eine etwas ähm,
Ja, so eine Jahresrückblickliche Perspektive zu einem Thema zu verfassen. Ich finde das ein äh sehr schön
sehr schön gelungenes Heft, was so auch vom Format her durchaus mal so ein bisschen zum zum Blättern einlädt. Also mir gefällt dieses Format.
Hier kommen auch Politiker zu Wort, Dorothee Bär und wie Brigitte Zypries im Interview.
Genau und es gab mehr gibt's, sind auch nochmal mehrere Interview.
Zum Thema Große Koalition Netzpolitik. Wo war das, eine Szene?
Artikel sind natürlich.
Ja, ja, natürlich mit MS Pro, wer sonst.
Er war, wo war das? Ich bitte dich.
Also ich stimme dir total zu. Äh ganz hervorragend gemacht. Bin wirklich beeindruckt. Das ist echt schick.
Ja, man fragt sich, wo die.
Das ist wirklich mal toll,
Ja, ich finde das auch den den richtigen Ansatz, das ist wirklich super. Ganz am Ende noch ein kleiner äh Erklärer und ein Glossar auch noch zu wichtigen letzpolitischen äh Begriffen. Da gibt's ja allerlei Abkürzungen,
zu erläutern und ein Impressum und fertig. Also das ist wirklich nett.
Ja. Also ist wirklich ein schickes Teil und ich kann mir das auch ganz gut vorstellen, so ähm dann zwischendrin sind immer so Zeitlinien pro Monat, ne, dann hast du irgendwie so DR August oder so, dann siehst du ja die Zeitlinie,
Ähm das ist schon sehr gelungen. Wie gesagt, nicht vollständig, habe ich ja schon angemerkt.
Also ohne Linus ist das natürlich äh ein Fail, ne, aber.
Haben sie gut gemeint? Nein, ist ein schönes Heft, ist wirklich ein schönes Heft. Ähm gibt's als E-Book dann im
PDF-Format für vier Euro neunzig. Die Printvariante ist mit vierzehn neunundneunzig nicht besonders äh günstig.
Aber eben auch ein fettes Heft, ja? Und ich denke, das kann man sich so schön mal hinlegen und wenn man dann die Jahresrückblicke, die dann so auf in Zukunft von zu erwarten sind,
da so ähm im Regal stehen hat, ist das äh sicherlich schön zum Durchblättern und.
Wo kann man sich das äh klicken?
Habe ich äh verlinkt.
Hast du verlinkt Ort? Sehr schön. Bei dir direkt.
Ja, ISBN Nummer.
Bei Amazon.
Also vierzehn neunzig und vier null.
Da linken wir dann noch direkt hier auf den Amazon Link auch noch mit drauf. Sehr hübsch.
Also du.
Blick ins Buch, kann man hier auch gleich noch äh machen. Das ist immer sehr schön. Das ist hier so ein Preview gibt, also wer da so einen Einblick bei, hm, ist kein kein Visiweg, ne?
Also bei dem bei dem äh Blick ins Buch ist es äh ist dieses schöne Layout dann nicht.
U sehen, ja das ist ja blöd. Na gut, wie auch immer.
Auch die Kindle-Version, die du gerade geblicken.
Ach so, verstehe. Druckbuch. Okay. Das kann man nicht.
Ah ja, ach so gibt's auch für Kinder. Also wirklich, wirklich feine Sache, steckt viel Arbeit drin und äh kommen gute Leute drin zu Wort. Ähm
kann man sich mal ins Regal stellen. Auf jeden Fall und auch mal durchblättern. Habe ich heute auf dem Weg hierhin gemacht. Und werde ich sicherlich auch zur Vorbereitung meiner eigenen Rückblicke auf das Jahr dann denke ich auch nochmal zu Rate ziehen.
Und dann sind wir am Ende der Sendung, wo wir heute ein Hörer der Woche benennen. Ja, es ist ganz eindeutig der Hannes.
Gerockt.
Hannes hat das sehr gerockt und der Hannes ist ein guter Mann.
Wird jetzt hier gelobt.
Der wird gelobt für sein Netz politisches Engagement.
Ja und das war's dann was erstmal.
Ja, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob also ich bin mal gespannt. Ich weiß es nicht, ja.
Immer noch eine Sendung hin vorm Kongress. Ich weiß es auch nicht. Und wir wissen auch noch nicht, ob wir eine Sendung auf dem Kongress äh hinbekommen.
Also ich will es auf jeden Fall versuchen, von dort aus was zu machen.
Ja, wir haben da ja eine kleine Ecke, das kann ich ja vielleicht nochmal kurz erwähnen, wenn ich das jetzt mal noch nicht erwähnt habe, also es gibt das.
Hast du letzte Mal erfüllt.
Habe ich schon erwähnt?
Ja, kannst du auch nochmal erwähnen? Ja, wen noch mal?
Soll ich's nochmal erwähnen? Ja genau, das schöne Sendezentrum äh wird ähm dort,
entstehen und ja wir haben schon einiges an Zuspruch bekommen von Leuten die dort mithelfen wollen, falls sich da noch weitere Leute finden,
gerne, ja und,
beim Kongress ist, sprecht uns an,
Ja, wenn ihr uns seht, irgendwie sagt hallo, sagt, ich höre äh Logbuch Netzpolitik, keine keine falsche Scheu, das ist immer sehr schön. Äh da Rückmeldungen zu bekommen, nicht wahr? Und ähm.
Besucht unsere Auftritte auf dem Kongress, ganz besonders glaube ich, kann man natürlich empfehlen, die Eröffnungsveranstaltung von Tim, äh die schon große Erwartungen geschürt hat.
Schauen wir mal.
Und ähm.
Spannend wird ja immer nur die Keynote. Ich mache ja nur die Eröffnung.
Ja, spannend, die Keynote ist ja noch nicht veröffentlicht, wer's sein wird, da.
Ja, deswegen ist es ja so spannend.
Noch Spekulationen äh drumranken.
Ja, es wird diesmal großes äh großes Tamtam gemacht.
Da wird großes Tamtam gemacht und da also sagen wir mal so der aktuelle Fahrplan hat ja jetzt schon weniger Lücken als als die erste Version, die veröffentlicht wurde ähm,
Die Lücken werden so langsam gefüllt, aber wir haben da noch ein bisschen was in der Hinterhand und das wird sicherlich sehr spannend. Jetzt ist aber, glaube ich, auch der Moment gekommen, wenn die äh wenn ihr diese Episode jetzt hört
Ist, glaube ich, auch der Vorverkauf vorbei. Wenn ich mich nicht täusche, endet der heute. Ähm,
Das hatte nur damit etwas zu tun, dass man kein, dass man verhindern möchte, dass dann da Leute sitzen und sagen, äh ich habe aber doch äh gestern Abend überwiesen. Das heißt, ihr könnt natürlich trotzdem dorthin kommen, ähm müsst dann
allerdings äh bar bezahlen am Eingang und.
Zumindest keine, ihr müsst keine Angst haben, dass ihr da nicht reinkommt.
Es gibt keine Anzeichen, dass wir die Bude vollkriegen. Was daran liegt, dass diese Bude unglaublich riesengroß ist.
Ja, genau. Das war's. Bis dann, tschüss. Ja, tschüss. Bis bald. Bis denn.
Ja, tschüss. Bis denn.